your statements they were pretty strong
you really tore into metro and the da's
office
not so much the da's office i'm not
upset with the district attorney because
the district attorney only responds to
questions when asked
the questions that were
not properly asked
by metro
metro asked a very specific question not
a broad question
and i called the sheriff and i said chef
libardo
why don't you ask some more questions
and he promised me that he would open up
an investigation
and he didn't
i'm like
why did you tell me you were going to do
this and you didn't
because the d.a actually asked me to
give him pass give him a second chance
be a good nevadan stephen and i was a
good nevadan i was
sheriff lobardo
do you not have the ability to lead
metro
are you a leader at all i don't know
this is not political you're being
political now sheriff lombardo because
you shouldn't be a partisan running
metro we know that
that's fact
what would you say to critics who say
you are making this political attacking
the sheriff directly because the sheriff
decided to run for governor and make it
political ask him
never before has the sheriff run for
governor and become partisan the
sheriff's always been nonpartisan he's
now running an institution as a partisan
it's a non-partisan job how does that
affect the investigation into the boxing
match though you tell me
ask the sheriff
he doesn't like to answer questions
watch ask him
why did he promise me to do an
investigation he doubled down
who's he talking to
what's his intent
what does he do right by this the
community be nonpartisan sheriff or step
down running for sheriff
being sheriff and go run for governor go
ahead go ahead but step down right now
kevin's kevin's been duly elected put
him in charge
you have a duly elected sheriff right
now kevin
put him in charge
chairman there was a lot of there was a
lot of back and forth today what really
came out what are we going to see next
out of this after today just like i said
it was a lot of back and forth
again let's see what metro does
they said they'd like to be helpful and
participatory and act like fellow
nevadans let's see if they do that i
know the dale do the right job once they
do their job metro
so it's your understanding that metro
will investigate now and bring those
results to you or the da's office just
so we're all clear you heard what metro
said here today
they said they'd like to be
participatory because i asked him would
you like to be participatory or you're
going to triple down he said he'd like
to be participatory let's see what they
do
actions speak
right
action speak
those are the facts
there's a little bit of a theme today
just small details being kind of you
know where
someone would say i didn't receive the
report i didn't send the report it
doesn't match these little details
what how do you think they add up for
you know such a
big you know
big consequence um you know
sorry i'm rambling here um just these
little details seem to be holding it up
there's nothing held up the report is
published read it
make your own decisions i did have a
question for you
russell black is mentioned in the report
and he's sort of affiliated with the
commission or do i understand that
correctly so did he have knowledge this
was going to take place
you read the report every everyone
that's been mentioned in the report
was notified via certified mail pursuant
of revised statutes that their name
would be mentioned today at this hearing
and what particular ways do you believe
the sheriff and by extension metro have
acted in a political manner as it
regards to the
i'm not saying that the the the
sheriff's acting is a political
i hope he's not acting in a political
manner if you're saying that the
sheriff's acting in a political manner
is that what you're saying no no no no
no that's what you just said
i hope not he's supposed to be
nonpartisan
i hope that he can wear different hats
like when he goes on the campaign trail
he puts his little r hat on you know it
goes trump trump trump
and you know does that kind of nonsense
but then when he was running metro he
puts on that nonpartisan hat and he has
a chinese wall i don't know ask him
ask him the tough questions you're the
reporters you're the journalists do it
do it what's your job have you
communicated with governor sislek about
the report and its findings no no that's
the attorney general's job to do with
the governor no
i'm sure the governor will call me after
this commission meeting and ask me how
it went and just to be clear
did anyone affiliated with the
commission know about this event prior
to it being held
no
no
how did you feel it went today
the facts are the facts
i stand by the facts
it's not my i don't have an opinion
i can read it
tell you what i think as you can read it
and tell me what you think
that's what democracy is all about
are you satisfied with the work by the
attorney general's office yes as i said
before the attorney general's office did
a phenomenal job along with nhp nevada
high patrol i am thrilled and honored to
work with them and i've worked with many
law firms around the country they are
the best and brightest and we should be
proud we have them in this state
with that i got to go thank you